it has been a rough few days man oh man
creating a mess blowing things around
and causing some folks to seek some
medical attention that's right earlier
today i spoke to one valley doctor about
some tips to stay safe
the wind is such an inconvenience it's
very very inconvenient the weather is
crazy my son asthma is out of control we
met porcha anderson outside a local
pharmacy she was looking for ways to
keep her son safe from the strong winds
during his upcoming birthday party the
only thing now that i can do is
definitely
keep him on his asthma treatment machine
so that's we're in and out the hospital
for his asthma but this family is not
alone according to dr rick vanuilla he
says it's a normal uptake trend for his
patients when we get extreme weather
changes umc reporting a 20 percent spike
in er visits related to wind for
respiratory issues the wind storms carry
with it a lot of irritants and you can
feel several times anywhere from simple
irritation of your eyes and your nose to
cough to even signs of an infection dr
vanua says there is a common arabic term
medical staff refer to high winds as
haboob lung syndrome which encompasses
all respiratory diseases if you don't
need to
stay outdoors please stay indoors with
the windows closed air conditioned on
simple suggestions this mother says she
plans to follow when the days are out of
control my allergies are out of control
i didn't even know i had these allergies
until the wind started happening so
it is a mess out there all right dr
venulia says that some symptoms can be
confused for covet 19. he says getting
tested helps and also wearing masks if
you happen to go outside like the n95
mask is highly recommended